in my time of watching anime there have
been few phenomenon as hit the anime
world I find it interesting at sword art
online mountain with 5 years that
originally started airing it goes
without saying that FAO s gone down the
history is one of the most popular anime
ever created
and has become a fundamental part of the
modern anime world never before has a
series divided the community so thesis
being the most simultaneously beloved
and hated anime of the modern era with
only just a mention of the name
guaranteed to start some kind of
argument so all watching saw that lani
of the day and what you like so not a
line uh no logic this [ __ ] awful noise
about you already done you should feel
bad what the [ __ ] is going on multiple
YouTube personalities myself included
have made a name for themselves by
talking about all making fun of it and
it's such a widely talked about topic so
it's gone from being really cool to hate
on saw dotted line so hating it being
treated as an outdated [ __ ] meme of
this community but now almost half a
decade down the line two seasons
multiple games our new film just around
the corner and a live-action Western
adaptation in work whether you love it
hate it well I just tired as hell people
talking about it there is one
irrefutable fact sword art online appear
to say and there's not a damn thing
anyone can do about it which ringless of
this videos topic so all this apparent
narrative flaws
flat characters and other critical
weaknesses dozen reports up time and
time and time again to the point that
both fans and haters are bored of
hearing the argument why is sword art
online so popular and why the hell has
me died yet
disclaimer I am NOT here to bash on
sawed-off online and my general opinion
of the series has not actually changed
much since my original review of its
four years ago back then I gave the
score six point five a my office last
day I still think it was mildly
entertaining nowhere near as bad as the
haters make it out to be nor as good as
the fans defend attacks and the other
reason I'd written it in the past is
because it has never not been relevant
to make a joke or two about it but we've
got to the point now where every insult
that can be said has been said only will
that every time I feel like making a
joke it will be via this snore last
online in Seoul generator I made
comprised of all the generic essay
no insults you've heard before and let's
see what our in Seoul of the day is the
Larsson line is Eddie dribble with an
overpowered Jesus [ __ ] as the
protagonist these are some cell
awesomesauce five things we can do even
better than this no there we go what a
classic incident no one has ever said
before Fiorina I wanted to make this
video is I think there is a lot going on
with how the scary 16 was a bigger
picture and so some interesting things
about our culture the wider anime
community and how shows get popular in
the first place and because making a
sword art online video on YouTube
guarantees you views we are a weekly
planner the ones that we start off with
the individual elements that make the
show popular which I always spent too
much time on as youtubers subsonic
Sparkle has already done a great job
breaking this down in his own videos
look summarize his point and once you've
seen SEO can probably guess of why it's
so appealing and marketable it has a
really strong hook and contains a very
wide range of topics and genres to have
mainstream appeal without delving too
deeply into any of them it has even
action and interesting concepts and
world where you don't have to be an
expert in any of the explore topics to
understand what's going on a more
definitive romance when you actually see
in most shows a protagonist blank enough
the viewers can protect themselves on to
while always in relation to him and
female characters are varied mix of
common female tropes whose men feel as
either just [ __ ] in just notice [ __ ]
ha okay the aesthetics are also very
appealing and there's a reason why accel
world which actually starts to airing a
season before it's but completely
overshadows last because what's more
appealing for an average viewer an edgy
badass swordsman who doesn't give a [ __ ]
boy literal [ __ ] blob it's
wish-fulfillment and escapism and is
simplest and I don't know why so many
people take this as an insult
shallow pub but entertaining hell yeah
who wouldn't want to be a badass
swordsman in a futuristic virtual
reality surrounded by hot chicks and a
loving girlfriend well he's so ashamed
to admit this hell if it was less
transparent about it I'm sure it would
have been far more positively received
it's the perfect gateway anime and while
I'm sure this doesn't cover white every
Sao fan like the series I think it
covers the wide mainstream appeal a bit
critical flaws and all by this logic
though the entirety of Sao span they
should just be horny teenage boys which
is actually not the case and most the
curious thing is for the amount of times
can criticise most Sao fans I've met are
very aware of its flaws and while a lot
of them are the annoying vocal fans and
making
cellphone and give the fanbase a bad rap
I don't think that alone can account for
the massive success of the franchise
there's a lot more going on than just
pretty aesthetics an appealing element
so to properly illustrate what happened
we need to look at how series can get
popular in the first place and so that's
not rewind with Highline back a bit this
is no ordinary animation this is the
exotic bizarre and beautiful world of
Japanese anime and this is your
invitation tender with a modern classic
of Kira where we look back at the
history of popular anime here in the
West there have been certain series that
have defined a generation and are
indicative of the culture at the time
Acura for example was a cult underground
hit in the VHS era that promoted an
amazing edgy adult alternative to any
other animation that was available at
the time from the late nineties hits the
famous tsunami block single-handedly
kick-started a whole generation of anime
fans introducing kids to likes of Dragon
Ball Z Sailor Moon Gundam Wing showing
them a new kind of cartoon unlike
anything that was available from Western
animation and of course this leads up to
the most recent shows that took over the
community before si over
[Music]
the sensation that caused the boom of
the anime well just over a decade ago
and what assessment was defensive for my
generation was of course the big three
Naruto Bleach and one
so what courtly show's popular wherever
IV or factors but a big part of it was a
timing in which they came out see in the
early 2000 these three shows up it's a
hotter day way animate in a time when
there was no real gateway animes the
horse shows of the previous era of
fading away leaving rooms capture the
attention of a generation I grew up
watching Dragon movies that were now
discovering the world of anime through
an entirely new platform the Internet
this was the new era of torrents and fan
club with a whole new generation of
anime fans being able to actually shows
that they could never have previously
seen before either due to cost of DVDs
or comes even on licensing everything
this started a huge boom in the fandom
and the free shows that was right in the
forefront of this were the big three to
put it simply there was a gap in the
gateway shows everyone looked awards and
there was a boom the fan and due to a
new platform for people to discover
anime by and if you look closely you can
see this passion for popular anime of
previous eras too so by the end of the
decade a new gap was emerging through of
the big three and the rousseau and
bleach was slowly coming to an end by
this point all the shows have been going
on for far too long to be as easily
accessible for newcomers of the am a
medium it was the end of an era and the
gradual start of a new one
I wonder Sao started airing in the
summer of 2012 a camera design when the
community was coincidentally searching
for the next big thing in a time when we
were getting a new surge of anime fans
because something else happened for
animated naturally in the late 2000
hey guys Victoria here and I'm a big
surprise the crunchyroll booth
crunchyroll a site that had previously
hosted the treatment service for illegal
fansubs of anime and dramas completely
turned around in order to pioneer the
legal streaming of anime currently
airing in Japan shows us we farmer cast
and premiered almost immediately after
they had aired in Japan which was
unheard of other side and for the first
time fansub could not compete this set a
new trend for anime streaming services
cap supporting the accessibility of
animates your whole new highs never
before was it so easy to watch anime
never before was there so much choice of
anime that we didn't have to wait for
Bible casting a screaming completely
changed the way the majority of the
community consumes anime and gave us an
immediate abundance of choice I was
always concurrent to what the Japanese
people thought what this meant was that
we had less patience for long-running
shows it became was about explosive
seasonal animes flavor of the week and
we became far less forgiving for things
like filler arcs were plagued for
victory and many long-running shonan's
which is why even though a lot of us
look to Shonen Jump what would be the
next big thing last year was changing so
fast we didn't realize we were looking
in entirely the wrong place the Akira
was a product of the VHS era Dragonball
Z a product of the television era us the
big three products of the Internet boom
and fansub era then shows like sword art
online and the tackling fight and I've
definitely products of the streaming era
there was a perfect gateway anime in the
time when a new generation was getting
into anime an entirely new way but then
that begs the question of why sword art
online in particular the gap in gateway
animate only really applies to Western
animation community and I mean sure has
mass appeal but so do a lot of other
shows what made this one stand out so
much from the plethora of new anime
people get to choosing Steven well it's
pretty simple really as for that we just
need to look at what our culture was
like at this time and in the 2000s the
biggest culture change I think we could
all agree on is our integration with
technology we're now on a sign when we
live our lives through our computer and
smartphone Twitter and Facebook have
similar way to our real-life persona
while YouTube and Netflix are slowly
taking over a traditional broadcast
media we're now live in an age where
digital technology has become an
essential part of our lives they're kind
of weird to think that free Wi-Fi is
more easily accessible for many of us
and clean water is for a lot of areas in
the world
so that's not deeply entwined VR with
technology around us many technological
advancements
the classmate and excite us through this
came the rise of a multi-billion dollar
industry gaming the rather 2000 went
from this rising industry the auditors
were obsessed with to one of the
journals of the entertainment industry
we now live in a time when talking about
the newest hottest games has become an
ordinary habit comparable to discussing
blockbuster movies or the latest
football scores I have become a staple
of mainstream culture
so obviously Anatomy up south gaming was
very clearly going to have mass appeal
so we'll listen like how many we can
name anime specifically targeted towards
gamers about games became before sword
art online you'd probably think until
tax franchise aka camping simulator 2003
an accel world which has already
explained but largely overshadowed by
FAO is felt but apart from that there
isn't much else is left because there
are so many gaming anime outs mouth
lots of my fiends who have forgotten
what it was like when FAO is first mouth
and the TV's really the theory seemed
like a genuinely [ __ ] cool fresh
concept an anime exploring the video
game world and looks awesome and had a
really interesting hook as they had
never really been a big high-profile
anime specifically about gaming before
this you may have had single episodes
exploring gaming or gaming tie-ins but
dedicated anime about gaming for modern
gamers that was new for us let's me I
felt like a breath of fresh air that's
from the Heidi outdated hat franchise so
I'm sure many of you are 1.4 then the
premise was cool and unique even if it
wasn't entirely original yes we had
strong the matrix or ghost Michele which
is called virtual worlds afforded yes we
have got hat which was the same concept
except the decade order just really
busted boring well the one big
difference between this is the timing in
which SEO came out is because the
remember what else was announced in 2012
even more than playing games I'm
passionate about bringing games to the
next level
my name is Palmer Luckey and I'm a
virtual reality enthusiast and the
designer of the risk yes we were on the
cusp of vr gaming itself do want me the
concept of Sao so enticing also it felt
like a world that could be within our
grasp
yes far enough technologically that it
seems wonder if an alluring it may have
not been the first group of people
accepting an MMORPG but it was the first
one that mattered framing in a way that
made it seem possible yet fantastical
which is why no matter how many animator
came up with the explore the concepts
that fell or FIFA they would
to be as relevant and anything that came
before it just seemed too far outs and
wagons to be relatable and see if that's
all it needed to do once it's to makes
itself as the new generation gateway
animate the ball except rolling starts
with perpetual language skyrocketed in
popularity you have a new generation of
fans discovering animates through the
hots gateway like FAO linking is the
greatest thing ever
meaning more veterans and the watching
FAO to see all the fuss is about causing
more discussions and arguments causing
more awareness meaning more people will
watch it which is how we get to where we
are today in other words your thoughts
online came at the right place at
exactly the right time but it doesn't
stop there either part of the reason it
hasn't died yet in this current flavor
of the week seasonal anime climate is
that it manages is wholly relevant
without ever repeating itself
Don Gale online feel to those about to
experience you have used first person
shooters friends that dominated triple-a
cycle to the five decade and its new
movie ordinal scale which is exploring a
port line using some fancy augmented
reality is coming just a year after Pope
on goats web through the globe and
augmented reality became a very possible
as significant technology in the world
the franchise continues to explore
topics that are ever so appealing to
this current generation even if it's
actual understanding of the games and
systems are pruned to be not the best
this is why after the GGO are 2200 no
one really talked about the rest of it
despite having arguably the best of the
franchise has ever done it didn't
explore anything new or relevant to many
viewers in the end sword art online is a
product of wide marketability massive
relevant and great timing it appeared
when the big cultural hits of a
generation were fading away and the new
technologically integrated generation
was searching for something fresh and
relevant and exploded fueled by new
services that blew the accessibility of
anime sky-high don't forget that one of
the reasons sawdust and life he also
popped up is because anime in general is
as popular as ever as better or worse
SEO is one of the shows that has defined
this generation of anime fans now if
that makes you mad if it makes you want
to start more flame wars or troll more
SEO fans then my word is probably not
going to stop you but you have to
realize that there will always be a
sword out of line there will always be a
Naruto there will always be a Dragonball
Z a decimal and Akira r1p and these show
still mean a lot to many people even to
this say
like in their prime the topic of all
these shows well as toxic as the topic
of Sao is today without the end of the
day sawdust alone was and continues to
be ever so relevant in the culture we
have now as much as we groan at it it's
a show that has gotten many new people
into anime
folks to a generation shows them
something new something that they could
relate was that nothing has ever shown
them before and we shouldn't forget
those first shows that flow to Isis our
generation and how close we hold those
shows no matter how flawed they were so
yeah hey Don si yo all you want laugh at
it or hell even defends it to keep up
you won't stop me from making the odd
rest here and there and it won't affect
the impact it's already had
we'll get your word in while you can
because once this generation we've done
something else to come along something
just as big it's not bigger or even more
controversial for us to all get heated
about again
[Music]
hey guys I hope you enjoyed this video
thank you very much this month - Andy -
IANA throwing melts for a charm no life
pecker sorry and everyone else in
pictures we're helping to support my
channel and making these video as
possible if you want to check out some
of the other stores online videos up
most and just click on the link on the
side I just want to keep up to date with
my latest doings and be sure to follow
me on Twitter
anyway let me this time though I've been
gig up and I'll see you all next time